Why are cities full of uncomfortable benches?
This one has armrests to prevent you from
dozing off.
to prevent you from taking a nap.
Here’s another — again with the arms,
the stiff metal.
And this one — it’s brand new.
The MTA in New York began installing them
as part of a subway enhancement plan.
And they don’t call it a bench.
They prefer the term "leaning bars."
So what if i told you it was designed with
discomfort in mind?
New York City is filled with some of the most
innovative architecture and urban planning
in the world.
Today, nearly every kind of public space here
is has been developed with close attention
to detail.
So these benches are no mistake.
They are designed to allow you to sit but
not get too cozy.
And that is intentional.
The concept stems from a school of thought
that goes by many names, but today
we'll use "defensive design."
Defensive design is about moderating behavior.
The goal is to limit the ways an object can
be misused.
These benches have armrests because that will
prevent anyone from laying down.
Their short back is another nod to say, "This
bench isn’t yours forever."
This trend is worldwide.
And it’s not just in the benches.
When you start looking for defensive designs
in New York City, you’ll find examples everywhere.
It’s the presence of security cameras in
subway turnstiles or Times Square.
It’s these spikes on this column, meant
to deter birds.
It’s the knobs on these ledges, to discourage
skateboarders.
And there were once sprinklers underneath
the awning of this bookstore, to prevent people
from sleeping there.
It's sidewalk barriers.
It’s even these regular streetlights.
Streetlights are probably some of the most
recognizable defensive designs.
When they surfaced in the 19th-century Western
cities, the dynamic of urban life changed.
More people spent time outside at night, which
drove economic development and a reduction
in crime.
Most hostile architecture tries to influence
behavior in a similar way.
The designs attempt to make public space a
bit more hospitable, more ideal.
Defensive designs can deter crime.
It can prevent the destruction of public property.
And it can prevent loitering.
But there is a reason why defensive design
is characterized as “hostile.”
Take the example of the bench again.
Disability advocates have a problem with that
appearing in the MTA.
One advocate pointed out that "People who
travel who have disabilities or just get tired
sometimes need a bench to sit on, not a wall
to lean against."
And while no one likes an uncomfortable bench,
these additions mean something more for people who are
experiencing homelessness.
The United States is currently experiencing
a decline in the overall homeless population.
But in New York, the homeless population is
growing.
About 1800 people were found to have been
sleeping in the subway.
That’s because emergency shelter isn’t
always a viable option.
There are several examples of hostile architecture
that target people who are homeless.
These designs imply that public space is not
where homeless people should be.
As it goes, city planners have a dilemma — how
do they design inclusive cities?
As for the enhanced subway initiative, the
MTA’s mock designs highlight new USB ports
and electronic signage in stations.
But you won’t find any press materials highlighting
this uncomfortable bench.
Excuse me, the "leaning bar."
That’s because it makes for an uncomfortable
discussion about who we design public space
for — and who gets left out.